ce candidat souhaité déposer son dossier
mais il manque la signature d'un
conseiller sur sa liste il va devoir
revenir
c'est toute la difficulté du processus
de dépôt des candidatures qui s'applique
depuis la loi de 2013 à toutes les
communes
je signe mon dépôt de candidature mais
chacun de mes collègues inscrit qu la
lys a signé également le dépôt de
candidatures donc c'est un engagement et
maintenant l'engagement il va tenir mais
pendant les six années qui arrivent
devant des démarches complexes et
nouvelle pour de nombreuses communes du
département
certains candidats ont préféré prendre
leurs précautions
c'est important pour vous de venir tous
les we parce qu'on ne savait pas le
temps qu'on allait y passer comme ça une
grande prière même pour le service
la préfecture nous avait bien expliqué
ya eu plusieurs réunions d'information
par les gens de la préfecture une fois
les dossiers déposés ils sont numérisés
pour la future soirée électorale
au total sept mille candidats sont
attendus pour l'arrondissement de dijon
seize mille pour tout le département
nous ne maîtrisons pas les flux
d'arrivée des candidats la seule
possibilité que nous ayons c'est d'avoir
donné des rendez vous pour les candidats
dans les communes de 19 conseillers
municipaux et plus de manières au moins
à avoir une maîtrise de ces flux là et
dès ce premier jour certains candidats
plus rôdé par le processus et non c'est
déjà leur combat à venir et leur
impatience à le mener où on veut
absolument de ce manifeste dans le pays
une opposition ouvrière à ce
gouvernement avec les travailleurs se
fassent entendre
et c'est une nécessité et une urgence et
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on a déposé la
liste dès le premier jour parce qu on
est dans cette urgence là
la période de dépôt des candidatures
court jusqu'au 6 mars 18h après cette
date la porte des municipales sera close